JAMES MALONE: Hi,
I'm James Malone.
Today, I'm here to talk about
what's new in open-source data
processing on Google Cloud.
So, today, I want to
talk about six things.
I want to talk about
who we are, and then I
want to talk about a
few key releases that
are really exciting for us,
Dataproc Metastore, Dataproc
Hub, some of our
open-source updates,
a few new features,
and then how you
can get started using our
managed open-source services
on Google Cloud.
First, I want to talk
about Open Data Analytics.
We're a group that's
passionate about combining
Google infrastructure with
the best of Google Cloud.
We think that open source
represents, in many cases,
the best of software.
It's community driven.
It moves quickly.
It really pushes the
envelope of what's possible.
We also think that Google
Cloud can run infrastructure
like nobody else.
So we're really
interested in combining
the power of open source
and the power of Google's
infrastructure to create managed
services so you can use managed
open source on Google Cloud.
We think that open source
should be efficient, secure,
and accessible.
Over the last year, we've
released over 40 releases.
And the reason I
bring this up is
we are very interested
in keeping up
with the open-source community
and all of the new releases,
but we also want our
customers to rapidly
have the latest and
greatest in both open source
and, also, Google Cloud
platform features,
things like VPC
Service Controls.
We think, the faster that
we can enable our customers,
the faster they have access to
the best of both open source
and Google Cloud.
One of our big new
releases that I'm really
excited to talk
to you about today
is the Dataproc Metastore.
So I'm going to give you an
overview of what the Dataproc
Metastore is and why we
have developed the Dataproc
Metastore.
The Dataproc Metastore is,
essentially, a managed Apache
Hive metastore.
So I want to start out with
why the Hive metastore is such
a big deal because
that drove why
we developed a managed metastore
service in the first place.
The Apache Hive
metastore is really,
as far as we see it, the
open standard for data lakes.
There's a lot of
tooling that depends
on the Hive metastore, things
like Hive, Presto, Spark,
Impala, Hudi, and many more.
There's also an emerging
set of open source
that uses the Hive metastore
in data lakes, things
like Iceberg and Delta Lake.
The Hive metastore integrates
with a lot of open source
that people use as part
of a data lake, things
like Kerberos, Ranger, Atlas.
And the metastore can
understand or represent
data that's in many different
places, things like Hadoop
clusters, cloud storage,
BigQuery, other cloud
providers, block storage,
Elasticsearch clusters, Kafka
clusters, and so on.
So, to put it simply,
the Hive metastore
is the central point
for open data lakes.
And it's a critical
path for any data
lake, which is built, at least
partially, on open source.
So it's very important
that Hive metastore
is usable and reliable.
So we developed the
Dataproc Metastore.
We recently announced that it's
in alpha public availability.
And the goal was to
have a fully managed,
highly available, and
open-source native Apache Hive
metastore.
We want to provide an Apache
Hive metastore service that
removes all of the barriers
for using both the Hive
metastore and the tooling
around the Hive metastore.
From our point of view, if we
give you the best managed Spark
or Flink service, it
really falls apart
without a well-managed
Hive metastore,
which is why we developed
the Dataproc Metastore.
It's also really
important-- and I'm
going to underscore
this point again--
that the Dataproc Metastore
is open-source native.
We don't want to limit what
people can do with the Apache
Hive metastore.
We want the Hive metastore
to be highly usable.
And, often, Hive
metastores sound simple,
but their actual
maintenance and operation
can be quite complicated.
Throughout our design of
the Dataproc Metastore,
we focused on
simplified management.
This is an example of creating
a new Dataproc metastore.
In this case, you can
see the creation screen
for just creating a metastore.
You can see that we only require
a few simple options, things
like a name, the
metastore version, where
you want to create
that metastore,
whether you want Kerberos
to be enabled or not.
This makes getting started with
the Hive metastore very, very
easy, essentially one click.
Likewise, we want
the Hive metastore
to be very compatible.
So, if you have an
existing Hive metastore,
we want it to be very easy
for you to bring your data
to the Dataproc Metastore.
In this example, we have
the import functionality.
This allows you to take
an existing Hive metastore
and import it into a
Dataproc metastore.
So it should be easy to
create a new metastore
and play around with the Hive
metastore and its tooling
if you're a new user.
Or, if you're already
deeply embedded and invested
in the Hive metastore
ecosystem, it
should be very easy to migrate
to use the Dataproc Metastore.
Throughout the design and
implementation of the Dataproc
Metastore, we've
wanted to create
a service, which is flexible,
integrated, and reliable.
In terms of flexibility, as
you're using the Dataproc
Metastore, if you
want to, for example,
scale your metastore up
because you have more users,
or you have added more tooling,
which uses the Hive metastore,
we want it to be
very easy for you
to manage that metastore, the
resources, who can control,
who has access to the metastore,
how it works, things like that.
We also want that
metastore to be integrated.
As I mentioned previously,
the Hive metastore
sits at the center of
an open-data ecosystem.
So it's really important
that the metastore
works with a lot of
things out of the box.
As an example, we've worked
with Collibra and Qubole
to make sure that they work out
of the box with the Dataproc
Metastore.
They're two examples,
but they showcase
that we're very
focused on making sure
that the Dataproc Metastore
is open and integrated.
Metastores are also
very difficult to run
because they are a critical
path in your ecosystem.
If the metastore goes down,
often, many things break.
So it's important to us that the
Dataproc Metastore is reliable.
And, from the ground up, we've
designed the Dataproc Metastore
so it's highly reliable.
There's another really
interesting feature,
which I want to
showcase up front today,
and that is Dataproc Hub.
Let's start with two personas.
On one hand, you have a data
scientist, and, on the other,
you have an IT administrator.
And say that both of
these people or personas
work for the same organization.
They have different needs.
The data scientist wants
to create notebooks
that are building blocks.
They want to create models.
They want to tinker and
experiment and explore
with data.
And, often, data
scientists want to do
this in a way that's unimpeded.
So they want to be able to
create a notebook and use
tooling.
And, often, data
scientists are preferential
to frameworks and tooling.
So they just want to get
started and hands on with data.
On the other, you
have IT administrators
who are concerned about
things like making sure
that code is production ready
and productionized properly.
They also care about costs and
controls and security, things
that the data
scientists might not
have front and center
in mind when they want
to get started with a notebook.
What this usually means is that,
when a data scientist wants
to create a notebook,
create a model,
and then get something
in production,
it can take weeks,
if not months,
and require a lot
of steps in between.
We think that things should
be much, much easier.
The data scientist should
be able to create a notebook
and then take that
notebook and have
it turn into
production-ready code
or productionalize their
notebook as easily as possible.
In essence, notebook should
be easy, configurable,
and all in one place.
There shouldn't
be a lot of steps.
There shouldn't be
a lot of friction.
And there shouldn't be a lot
of organizational frustration
in trying to both enable
notebooks and also control them
at the same time.
So we built Dataproc Hub.
We recently announced
Dataproc Hub in open beta.
And Dataproc Hub is
built in conjunction
with the AI Platform Notebooks
functionality on Google Cloud
platform.
Ultimately, what
this means is that we
are bringing data scientists
and IT administrators together.
And we're also bringing
notebooks together
with AI Platform
tools and Dataproc.
As a result, data scientists
can easily create notebooks.
They can choose their
favorite open-source tool kits
and frameworks.
And they can use advanced
features on Google Cloud
platform on Dataproc clusters,
things like GPUs or SSDs
if they have workloads
that are IOPS performant.
What this means for
IT administrators
is that they can predefine who
can do what with notebooks,
what the size and shape
of Dataproc clusters
looks like, what features
are automatically enabled
or disallowed.
It also makes it very easy
for these IT administrators
to see exactly who
is using notebooks
and then take what's being done
and productionalize it very,
very easily.
The IT administrator story
is really important to us,
as we think about notebook use.
And, as the first--
it's optional, but,
as a first step,
an IT administrator
can predefine who
can do what with Dataproc Hub.
Specifically, what this
means is an IT administrator
can predefine what size,
shape, location, and features
are used in a
Dataproc cluster that
powers a Dataproc Hub notebook.
That way, once somebody gets
their Jupyter-based Dataproc
Hub notebook, all
of the constraints
are automatically applied
for the cluster that runs
and powers that notebook.
In this example, we have
a YAML-based cluster
configuration that specifies
an idle configuration.
So, in this case,
the cluster would
be deleted if it was idle
for more than 7,200 seconds.
An IT administrator can
use this configuration
as a template for clusters that
are then used for Dataproc Hub
notebooks.
So, if a cluster is idle, it
automatically gets deleted.
And this showcases
how we're trying
to bring both data scientists
and IT administrators together
with Dataproc Hub.
Ultimately, the flow
of using a notebook
with Dataproc Hub and
AI Platform Notebooks
should be fairly easy.
The data scientist can go
look for examples or snippets
in AI Notebooks Platform or
go directly to Dataproc Hub
to create new notebooks or
reuse existing notebooks.
Then they can use that notebook
and Dataproc or BigQuery
to prepare, process, and
create models, data sets.
All the while, the
IT administrator
can see who's doing
what with notebooks.
They can preconfigure
the boundaries
on what notebooks can do in the
clusters that underlie them.
And then they can do
things like schedule
and manage notebooks
that have already
been created by Dataproc Hub.
Ultimately, this is
showcasing that it
can be a frictionless process
between data scientists and IT
administrators.
It also makes it very easy
to create Dataproc clusters
with Jupyter-based Dataproc Hub
notebooks for data scientists.
So there's fewer hoops
to jump through when
you want to do data science.
So, in this case,
I'm going to show you
what a quick demonstration
of Dataproc Hub
looks like to show you why
it's really easy to get
started with Dataproc
Hub to do data
science with open-source tools.
So, in this example,
I am a data scientist,
and I want to maybe
use Spark and BigQuery.
So I know I can go to AI
Hub and find some examples
for common situations.
In this case, I'm
going to see if there's
an example for how to use
Spark with BigQuery together.
So I search for
BigQuery here, and I
will get a list of results.
And, in the results, I can
see that there is indeed
a quick example showing how
to use Spark with BigQuery.
And this is using the
Spark-BigQuery connector
that's provided on Dataproc.
I then can take that
example and open it
in the AI Platform Notebooks.
And I already have a
preconfigured workbench
that an IT administrator
has preconfigured for me.
I then sign in.
So Dataproc Hub does
perform the authorization
and authentication checks.
And you can see that the cluster
that is behind this notebook
has been already preconfigured
by the IT administrator.
So, as a data scientist, all I
need to do is just click Start.
This creates the notebook.
It also creates the
cluster that powers
the notebook behind the scenes.
You can see in this example
that all the data scientist had
to do was click
Start, and they got
the notebook and the cluster.
They don't have to think
about configuration.
They don't have to think about
networking plumbing or cluster
options.
The data scientist
doesn't even necessarily
have to know what Dataproc is.
All they did was create a
notebook and get started.
Beyond Dataproc
Hub, I want to talk
through some of the really
important open-source updates
that we've provided on Dataproc
in the last several months.
We make it a point to
keep up with the latest
and greatest in open source.
And we're really
passionate about bringing
new open-source developments
to you in Dataproc as a managed
service.
One of the big advancements
that I want to showcase
is Dataproc 2, which just
entered public preview.
Dataproc 2 includes some
significant upgrades
in the default
components that we
install on Dataproc clusters.
What this means is you get
Hadoop 3, Spark 3, Hive 3.1,
Java 11, and several other
upgrades to components
that we put on
clusters by default.
We keep the number of components
that we install by default
somewhat slimmed down.
So you have efficient clusters.
And we narrow the installs down
to the most-used components,
but there's still a
whole set of things
you can install on
Dataproc clusters
through initialization
actions, custom
images, optional
components, and other means.
These optional
installs have also
been updated in
Dataproc image 2.
So it includes things
like Apache Flink,
updates to Apache HBase,
Druid, Presto, and others.
So Dataproc 2 is a
brand new image line
in Dataproc designed to bring
the Hadoop 3 and Spark 3
ecosystem to you.
I specifically want
to talk about Spark 3
because Spark 3 includes
a number of really
interesting and
important updates
that we're excited both
to bring you in Dataproc,
and we're very
interested in seeing
how we can bring
these functionalities
and improvements to
future Dataproc features.
So the theme for Spark
3 was performance,
and there's three
good examples of what
that means for you in terms
of performance in Spark 3.
First, Spark 3 includes
better adaptive query support.
So Spark can
optimize a query plan
while things are executing.
Spark 3 also has dynamic
partition pruning.
So unnecessary scans
are avoided in queries
that could look like
data warehouse queries
so, again, faster querying.
Spark 3 also has
improved GPU support,
and we're really
excited because we
think there's a future where
Spark 3 can run entirely
on GPUs, both for data
science and, potentially, just
general data processing.
So we're very interested in
seeing what the future holds
for Spark and GPUs.
There's also a lot of
advancements for Spark
running on Kubernetes.
I'll talk about
it in just a bit,
but Dataproc has a
flavor, which allows
you to run Spark on
Kubernetes clusters
that are managed by Dataproc.
So we're very excited to see
new advancements in Kubernetes
and Spark because it will
only make both the Spark
community better, but also
makes Dataproc a much more
interesting product from
a Kubernetes perspective.
I mentioned GPUs
before, but this
is something that's really,
really exciting to us.
And we've worked
closely with NVIDIA
to make sure that GPUs
work well in Spark
and also that GPUs work well
on GCP and Dataproc clusters.
So you can create Dataproc
clusters with NVIDIA GPUs
today.
We've also worked with NVIDIA
on things like the RAPIDS
frameworks to make sure
that you can do really
high-performance data
processing and data
science on Dataproc clusters.
If you're interested in
using Spark 3 with GPUs,
I would highly
encourage you to look
at the documentation on
the Dataproc site and also
the RAPIDS framework.
We think this is a really
interesting avenue for Spark
in open source in the
long term to run on GPUs.
It's very easy to get started
with Dataproc 2 today.
All you need to do is
specify that you want
to run the preview of Dataproc.
So this is an example
of a Cloud SDK command
or a gcloud that specifies
the preview image.
I also want to call
out how easy it
is to use different sets
of open-source components
on Dataproc clusters.
You don't have to
think about upgrading
one whole cluster to new
versions of Spark or Hadoop.
If you want to try out
a new version of Spark,
in this case, Spark 3, create
a very small new cluster
and use the preview image.
Try a job out.
Try some of the
new features out.
Then you can delete the
cluster when you're done.
Dataproc imaging is
a subtle feature,
but makes it very
easy and interesting
to try out different
sets and versions
of open-source
components without fear
of breaking clusters
that are running
production or high-value jobs.
There's also a whole set
of new Dataproc features
that I want to run
you through as well.
As I mentioned, we have
a flavor of Dataproc,
which runs on Kubernetes.
We've recently announced
Dataproc on Kubernetes Engine
clusters in beta.
What this means is that
you can run Spark jobs
with Dataproc on GKE clusters.
We are really excited about the
future of running open source
on Kubernetes clusters.
I'll give you three
examples of why.
One, we think that it allows
better resource management.
So you can have multiple
things running on one cluster
and be a little bit more
sure that resources are being
balanced and managed properly.
It also allows you to take
one Kubernetes cluster
and run open-source
data processing
with something like
a web application
if you were so inclined.
It also potentially allows
for better job isolation.
And, as customers get
better resource management,
job isolation is something
that goes hand in hand.
We're also really interested
in both seeing and helping
these open-source
frameworks and tool kits
work with some of the more
advanced and interesting
features on Kubernetes,
things like auto scaling,
node healing, and the
like, because that
allows for more dynamic
clusters over time.
The Dataproc has been involved
in getting both Spark and Flink
working on Kubernetes.
Last year, we released
both an operator
for Spark and Kubernetes.
Because it's a
common question, I
do want to call out that
we will support both YARN
and Kubernetes well
into the future of data.
We're not making a
wholesale decision
to switch from one to the other.
We see customers over
the next several years
will want to use both
for different reasons,
and we have a plan to support
both YARN and Kubernetes well
into the future.
Another feature that I'm
really excited to mention
is Dataproc flex mode.
I'll explain flex mode through
a problem with both scaling
and virtual machines.
When you're trying
to scale down,
you may hold on to a
node or a set of nodes
because they have
intermediate data.
They finished processing.
They're just holding
on to something
that they can't get rid
of, but, otherwise, you
would get rid of the node.
Likewise, with
preemptibles, you may
have a node that's finished
processing or reached
a state where it can checkpoint,
but the node is preempted.
In both cases, if
you removed the node,
you would lose the data.
Flex mode is a
stateful data store
that allows you to
store stateful data,
such as MapReduce shuffle
data, in HDFS on the cluster.
This makes clusters
more flexible
because you can add and remove
clusters much more easily
without interrupting your job.
So, in my example, if
you wanted to scale down,
once the node is done computing,
it can put all of its data
in flex pool, and then the node
can simply be auto scaled down.
Likewise, if you lose
a preemptible VM that's
finished processing,
that preemptible VM
has already put its
data in the flex pool.
So its preemption presents
no risk to your job.
Flex mode should allow
better auto scaling
and also should allow you
to use more preemptibles
in your Dataproc
clusters, which,
again, means greater flexibility
and cost optimization.
There's two new
security features,
which we're adding to the
pile of pre-existing Dataproc
security features.
So Dataproc already allows
you to use security features,
such as Ranger, customer-managed
and customer-supplied
encryption keys, Kerberos, VPC
Service Controls, our component
gateway, which
allows you to access
web UIs with no networking, but
still provides authorization.
All of these are
great, but customers
have told us they
want more security,
which we've been
squarely focused on.
And these are two of multiple
new security features,
which you'll see in the future.
One of the security features
is secure extensions
for notebooks.
What this means is that
you can give somebody
a notebook, and that someone
or that data scientist,
for example, their
credentials will
be used for execution of
the job and to communicate
with whatever services
that job connects with.
So, for example, if I
am a data scientist,
and I interact
with Cloud Storage,
my data scientist
individual credentials
will be used to go
talk to Cloud Storage,
instead of a service account.
And this brings better
per-user isolation and security
to notebooks.
A second feature that
we recently announced
was Shielded VMs.
So, if you're using
Dataproc clusters
with Ubuntu 18 or Debian 10,
you can use Shielded VMs.
Again, these are two new out
of future security improvements
that you'll continue to see
in Dataproc to make sure
that customers have all
of the security features
both that they might want, but,
also, that we could potentially
offer as a cloud provider.
I want to finally
mention something
that doesn't get a
lot of attention,
but is kind of a continual
feature in Dataproc.
And that's additional
compute flexibility.
Every time there's a
new region or a new VM
type or a new
accelerator, we try
to wire those
through to Dataproc
as quickly as possible.
What this means is you get
new levers for cost and speed
optimization.
In this example, say that
you had a workload, which
was performance
insensitive, and you just
wanted to lower your cost.
You could use E2 machine types
to lower your cost relative
to maybe you were running
on N1 standard forms.
You can see on the table
all of the VMs kind of look
and feel the same, but
the cost is different.
This is an example of how
additional compute flexibility
can give you some really
powerful levers to speed things
up or to optimize cost,
depending on your needs.
Finally, I want to
talk about how you
can get started with Dataproc.
The best place to get
started with Dataproc
is our documentation on
the Google Cloud site.
We also have a set of tutorials
on the Dataproc site, things
like using Spark with
BigQuery or creating clusters
to run Presto.
So you should be able to
run through those tutorials
to understand Dataproc and
some of the open-source tooling
pretty quickly.
If you're brand new
to Google Cloud,
I really encourage
you to take a look
at the free trial for
Google Cloud Platform
to get started with both
Google Cloud and also Dataproc.
If you're curious about
Dataproc or you're
an existing Dataproc
customer and want
to know more or participate,
we have a Stack Overflow tag,
google-cloud-dataproc,
which you can
use to find questions
and ask new questions.
Often, you'll see the
Dataproc engineering
team trying to help customers
and Stack Overflow users.
We also have a Google Group,
cloud-dataproc-discuss,
and a feedback email list.
And please do send us your
feedback and thoughts.
It's customers that
largely influence and help
drive our road map.
So we are passionate on hearing
and responding to our customers
and whatever needs you may have.
With that, I want to thank
you very much for your time,
and have a great day.